first of all it was with my next-door
neighbor
and she said no you have to get some few
things to get together and you must come
with me and next minute i knew there was
two police officers behind her
it came in a house and and just said
like describe what you can well i used
to go get a top and i went upstairs he
followed me the police officer and took
the top and just gave it to me so what
did you take when you left that must
have been so scary he said um
just take what what you can but
you mustn't take
anything else
but
your
your personal belongings and that was it
he said no quickly and i
he said um
i said my partner has got copd
he can't breathe he's not allowed out of
the house
and he's panicking so the police
obviously just got hold of him and and
we had to go at the house and he just
shut the door
after us
did you see the fire lin yes tell me
describe it to me
um we we thought it was just one of the
fields that caught a light over the back
of us
but uh then a neighbor rang me and and
said to me oh no then it's what on the
green
the green has caught fire
so
i thought oh
and then i saw all this black smoke and
then
the helicopters start coming over
and more police
coming into our neighborhood and um
and it was it really spreading very fast
i think that was what surprised me that
the way the winds were moving this fire
can you describe the village to me
describe give me a sense of what the
village is like the village is very a
very good community village
um
uh what i can say is because i've been
been here for quite some time
and although things change all over the
place but we are very good community we
all you know
connect with one another and that's why
i had so many phone calls to sail in
you've got to get out
and can you describe how you're feeling
how's your husband right now he's not
breakers
because of his
he can't even the heat is bad enough
without being indoors
and um he's a and he didn't have time to
to bring his inhaler with him
and uh so he's not too good at the
moment and we obviously knew this
extreme weather had extreme risks as
well did you though ever imagine it
would be on your doorstep like this no
never never
no it just spread that quickly i think
what it is
the wind
that that
caused the wind to
to go our way towards the village yes
but your home is safe though yeah
yes
at the moment thank you so much so much
and
sarah jane you can see residents like
lynn from the village just gathered on
the outskirts not really knowing where
to go they've now all their homes have
been evacuated the cordon itself is
being pushed back and back and as we've
been here we've been seeing more and
more units from the emergency services
arriving you've probably heard of fire
engine police units are here as are the
ambulance teams as well it's a very
changing picture and as yet the fire
still feels incredibly dangerous because
of these winds making the direction of
that fire simply impossible to guess at
the moment